principal one-point-seven pain plus
reflection equals progress there is no
avoiding pain especially if you're going
after ambitious goals believe it or not
you were lucky to feel that kind of pain
if you approach it correctly because it
is a signal that you need to find
solutions so you can progress if you can
develop a reflective reaction to psychic
pain that causes you to reflect on it
rather than avoid it
it will lead to your rapid learning and
evolving after seeing how much more
effective it is to face the painful
realities that are caused by your
problems mistakes and weaknesses
I believe you won't want to operate any
other way it's just a matter of getting
in the habit of doing it most people
have a tough time reflecting when they
are in pain and they pay attention to
all the things when the pain passes so
they miss out on the reflections that
provide the lessons if you can reflect
well while you're in pain which is
probably too much to ask
great but if you can remember to reflect
after it passes that's valuable too I
created a pain button app to help people
do this which I'll describe in the
appendix the challenges you faced will
test and strengthen you if you're not
failing you're not pushing your limits
and if you're not pushing your limits
you're not maximizing your potential
though this process of pushing your
limits of sometimes failing and
sometimes breaking through and deriving
benefits from both your failures and
your successes is not for everyone if it
is for you it can be so thrilling that
it becomes addictive life will
inevitably bring you such moments and it
will be up to you to decide whether you
want to go back for more if you choose
to push through this often painful
process of personal evolution you will
naturally ascend to higher and higher
levels as you climb above the blizzard
of things that surround
you you will realize that they seem
bigger than they really are when you
were seeing them up close that most
things in life are just another one of
those the higher you ascend the more
effective you become at working with
reality to shape outcomes toward your
goals what once seemed impossibly
complex becomes simple